[Music]
hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for honor again for the
second video of today and today we're
gonna be doing it the new mythic outfit
that just came out for the nights it's I
believe it's called the pledge of heaven
basically we're gonna be doing a few
games with gladiator since that is my
preferred main character collapse um
kid's cheeks and duals show off the
outfit as much as possible and just have
a little bit of fun with some commentary
as well
hopefully you guys would enjoy this if
you guys do enjoy this though I will
most likely be doing more videos of this
and I'm probably gonna be experimenting
with a lot of things adding background
music changing the volume and even maybe
not even doing commentary so tell me
what fits most whether the sound and the
game should be louder if there should be
no commentary throughout the match at
all anything like that just let me know
in the comments below and I'll try to
incorporate that in the next video
as always like the video if you did
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the leaks the informational side of for
honor the news the patch notes and other
stuff like that I'm also just trying
something new for today that being a
little bit of gladiator gameplay but I
do mostly do informational side like
news patch notes leaks reworks all that
stuff upcoming updates for for honor to
keep everyone in touch and with that
let's get started with the video any
first character in the first match we're
gonna be fighting is a Centurion he
starts out with that top easily easily
dodgeball stuff like that give him that
quick boom mixup with the toe stab even
get around to him here
another toast that inched that more
damage hit him with that zone definitely
probably he probably shouldn't have
fainted that though I'm really glad he
didn't cuz that the cost that would have
that definitely costed him some damage
and with that simple zone and GG not bad
I'm still getting used to gladiator this
is my first match playing with him today
so I'm getting a little bit better with
that as well as trying to commentate
during these fights as best as possible
and not trying to sound annoying but for
this fight we're gonna try to get an
execution show off that new execution
with this mythic outfit looks really
nice I had it obviously in the preview I
thought it looks really cool good parry
I got him done do about three bars not
bad okay so he's done all right so he
knows the timing with that so we're
definitely gonna be using that a lot
less okay oh I was mid here that's fine
damn okay I still gotta get a little bit
more used to that all right and we get
the execution right on the ledge too I
wonder I think I was told that this
ledge is so hopefully we can get him to
ledge off Tori and nice okay good good
[ __ ]
yeah good flight sent heading in a round
three hopefully it will try to get this
three zero flawless scent is pretty fast
with this heavy so I gotta be aware to
faint not as much because that could
cost me some hits got a little bit of
that back step out of the way hit him
with that real quick zone since it's
disgustingly powerful he doesn't know
I hope okay you know good toast let's
try go for the GAR break but I step back
a bit that's what I was trying to do go
for that feint good stuff did I good
good guard break try see if I can go for
another execution but it looks like I
won't be able to but I'll just end the
fight real quick there good flight scent
good 302 start the day good stuff and
for our second match the next opponent
is going to be a beserker and I'm not
really good against Berserker cuz it was
400 m/s lights on Council they're
absolutely devastating on PC they still
are but not in not as much as council
because of our 30fps so I'm gonna see if
I can try to get a win I haven't once
again I'm not really that good against
berserkers especially if they're really
good at faint things so we'll try it out
we'll see what's up
alright good feint there
I got to be aware not to do too many
side attack moves or jump in you know
jump the - forward light cuz I know just
go around it and then that's not good
cuz then I'll take some hefty damage and
I'll lose that trade good feint I almost
had that side - you know how I didn't a
good fight I don't know how you I don't
know how well you guys do against
Berserker but personally to me he's
probably one of my hardest matchups to
do so that's why it's all about a
learning experience regardless if I lose
this fight or not I have to get slightly
I get slightly better fighting observers
so it's all it's all good
is move Abed out of stamina I'm gonna
problem gonna get my stamina back after
he does which is not a good thing okay
they'll come back with it the hyper
armor on that top heavy definitely
costed me a little bit help there we're
almost done even footing his own attack
will definitely screw me up so I gotta
watch out for that a good fight did
pretty close match I tried though put a
little bit passive this one he usually
in the Pat in the first two rounds he
didn't really go in as much he actually
let that one rip I think we try to parry
one of these lights get myself some
decent damage off the start here it's
kind of necessary this man's doesn't
like to use the heavies as the opener
he'll always like to feint the heavy
into a decent zone right away all right
a little bit of a cheese there with the
dashing forward into the light but he
kept backing up every time I did it so I
almost died there that definite would
have been really shitty if I ended up
dying but either way good fight bill for
I'll see I have to basically come back
the big comeback give give this dude the
absolute choke to win this game
hit her with that random heavy since he
was gonna guard break all that him
finishes his call on him finish his
moves should have went for that zone
attack since it does more damage in the
light but either way I still got the
decent damage I'm gonna go for the guard
bricks amount of stamina casual
berserker miss that zone I'm gonna hit
my zone GG real quick match flawless
good fight dude coming back to basically
develop in these duels that since you're
no one people in setting you don't have
to worry about the opponent the other
opponents around you an external attack
so you could basically focus on him and
learn his play style since he always
likes to do heavies and then feint them
into lights as the opener I usually
watch out for those very very often like
that the simple heavy the simple heavy
cancel into the little faint therefore
the opener since he never really felt
like those rip he'll probably try to do
another heavy uh or just rip that that
works too but and I'd missed the zone
again sadly a good zone now he's out of
stamina which is bad for him he knows
it's coming out cuz he knows I did that
top he's good on him
all right Steph he's definitely catching
on to my play style which is really nice
gotta watch out just thinking and I'd
miss this on it I'm not really good at
hitting his own attacks as the ending
there for that heavy for the heavy Perry
either way got that three to win against
observe a really tough match though but
good flag though good stuff
he seems to be doing the Berserker once
again so this will probably be the third
and final match of the day hopefully can
get another win against this Berserker
since he was pretty damn good last game
doing his normal bashes again and since
this is basically the same opponent I
could basically just take whatever
writes up from last match into account
from this match this is he seems to be
doing that type of thing over and over
again still waiting on the heavy feint
into light see if I could try to get a
move with that not letting him get any
chances for two guard break on me just
constantly hitting the light attacks on
him and that was an easy GG right there
good fight dude we're gonna try to show
off the execution just a little bit more
in the emo and all that other good stuff
so I'm gonna see if I could try to get
execution since I didn't get any on him
last game since of him being a Berserker
he was basically going all over the
place see if I can try to land one this
match
good hit missing that guard break which
is super crucial right
he knows that stuff is coming since he
did it last time
I definitely didn't see that coming good
hit though somebody try to think see if
I could try to fake this real quick ah
good flight though I try to get that
execution and have costed me a little
bit of a loss but oh well let's try to
get him next round like I said he does
that heavy opener and then like he does
the heavy and then cancel it into a
light and he did it just then and I
caught on to it he also likes to do the
top he also likes do the top heavy
unblockable and do the same exact thing
so I have to watch out for that as well
when I do these fights he doesn't seem
to know the timing on the pit on the toe
step which is really nice so I can
utilize that to my advantage
that one he definitely probably assumed
since he's basically just gonna be
backing up since he's out of stamina and
knows that gladiator with that toe stab
didn't make getting him down understand
would be very bad who's definitely to
start backing up you know what to try
try to hit him with the zone didn't end
up hitting it but that costed him just a
little bit cuz he could have got an easy
guard break but didn't I'm surprised
usually they like to do that a lot
I'm trying to keep my distance since I
know he's gonna do some weird attack or
so or [ __ ] up something like that
surprise I didn't get the hit though
he's definitely blocking all my attacks
now like normal which is nice he's
reading my movements which is
interesting he's definitely gotten
better since the last match we played
[Music]
and good fight did dodge that zone
attack just in time for the good
execution there my stuff was getting a
little bit risky there I was just try
taking about going to just hit the light
attack but I wanted to show off the
execution just a little bit more so I
tried to do that and it worked out
pretty good he definitely ran out of
stamina when he hit that zone which even
if I didn't manage to hit that gar brick
would have costed him a little bit he
would have been playing a lot more
passive but regardless he was out of
stamina and I wasn't which tough way
puts him at a disadvantage thought the
fight I don't know why I do that move
but I like to hit the skewer with the
heavy since I'd like to dodge and the
dodge recovery frames and all that good
stuff usually gets me a decent heavy I
don't know why I let that rip on me that
was bad I was bad idea on my part see if
I could do the infamous don't cancel at
the top light
you have to watch out with those
berserkers though they usually like to
hit the zone and then try to get that
guaranteed light afterwards it usually
never works out try to get that gar
break it's fine he'll probably try to
open up but the top heavy he stopped
yeah and he's getting me with the light
I'm surprised I didn't get that but I
got the I got the following light and I
got the execution good stuff as I've
reiterated multiple times during the
fight though you obviously have to read
hit the opponent because if everybody
knows their bread-and-butter moves
they'll do it consistently until it's
blocked or known he'd like to do that
heavy cancel too heavy into another
light from a different direction I
basically got that down any and then
eventually only in this way I noticed it
he ended up doing the same thing but
with the top heavy unblockable fainting
that into another light once I got that
down I was able to sadly I didn't block
it though but I did know it was coming
but I blocked the following light
afterwards so you always have to be
reading your opponent and all that type
of good stuff during your fight but
anyway guys it's going to be the end of
the video today guys hope you guys did
enjoy some a little bit knew I did it a
while back when gladiator first released
but I've had a lot more of a following
so I would get a lot more people's
opinions on this type of stuff and
everything be interested to hear what
you guys want would you guys want more
of this no commentary yes commentary
anything that any of your thoughts at
all would be great I'd really be highly
appreciated as always liked the video if
you guys did enjoy uh subscribe if
you're new I cover the leaks the
information they'll side the patch notes
the news anything regarding the info the
new side of for honor I like to cover as
well as some random stuff like this
which I'll probably try to incorporate
more of well regardless I like to cover
the news the most my two most recent
videos gonna be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out and with that
guys so baby girl yesterday thank you
guys for watching the video tell what
you guys think and peace out